TODD KERPELMAN: Hello, I'm Todd
Kerpelman for The Developer
Show, and this is your weekly
update on the coolest developer
news from Google.
Android Studio 3.4 is ready to
download on the stable release
channel.
This update includes
a new resource manager
for improved asset management,
a new project structure
dialogue as a front end
to manage Gradle project
files, R8, replacing
ProGuard as the default code
shrinker and deobfuscator,
as well as over 300--
whew, 300-- bug fixes and
stability enhancements.
To get started with
Android Studio 3.4
and find out
everything that's new,
check out the link in the post.
The Cloud Functions
for Firebase team
has released a turnkey solution
for secure scheduled functions
using Firebase tools and SDKs.
So if you want to
schedule a function
to run on a regular basis,
similar to a cron job,
Firebase now has a special Cloud
Functions convenience method,
which will do this for you.
How convenient.
To find out more about
how to use this new method
and see some sample code, check
out the details in the post.
The Indie Games Accelerator
is a special edition
of Launchpad accelerator
to help top Indie game
developers from emerging markets
achieve their full potential
on Google Play.
The team is very
excited to announce
that applications for the
class of 2019 are now open.
Selected participants will
attend two gaming boot camps
all expenses paid at the
Google office in Singapore
where they will
receive personalized
mentorship from Google
teams and industry experts.
Details about the program and
instructions and how to apply
are on the post.
In order to better protect
you and your users from
man-in-the-middle attacks,
Google will block sign-ins from
embedded browser frameworks
like the Chromium Embedded
Framework, or CEF,
starting in June.
If you are currently
using CEF for sign-in,
you should switch to
using browser-based OATH
authentication.
This also enables users to
see the full URL of the page
where they're entering
their credentials, thereby
reinforcing good
anti-phishing practices.
More details about
this change are--
you guessed it-- on the post.
Deep neural networks
are great at solving
hard problems such as image
classification and text
recognition.
However, designing a
network from scratch
for your specific
application can
be a challenging task in terms
of computational resources
and time.
One solution to this
problem is MorphNet,
a sophisticated technique
for neural network model
refinement.
MorphNet takes an existing
neural network as input
and produces a new neural
network that's smaller, faster,
and yields better performance
tailored to a new problem.
More details about
MorphNet as well as
the open source TensorFlow
implementation are on the post.
Hey, did you like this video?
Well, why not like,
subscribe, and share?
I'm Todd Kerpelman for
The Developer Show.
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
[CLAPPING FAST]
This was, like, the
world record [INAUDIBLE],,
and, like, this
is how he did it.
SPEAKER 1: Uh-huh.
TODD KERPELMAN: I don't know.
It's a thing.
SPEAKER 1: What was the record?
Do you remember?
TODD KERPELMAN: Much faster
than I am able to do it.